high school students in Oregon will not
need to perform proficiency tests
showing Mastery of Reading Writing or
math in order to graduate this is a
controversial decision and one that's
facing a lot of push back while some say
the decision will lower state standards
and cheapen an Oregon diploma the Oregon
Department of Education tells me this
policy simply didn't work and
disproportionately harmed students of
color Yes uh students of color are
having a hard time learning and so the
solution is to give up on requiring them
to learn it's exactly the same as saying
that like I don't know a
disproportionate number of black people
are failing to wear their seat belts and
so we're going to remove seat belts
completely from Vehicles as a solution
to that